so I heard today is bring your wife to
work day and today I get to visit my
CUNY husband at work hello how does it
feel
um it's good because then I can see what
I do
um why I spent so much time here and
then all the hard work that I put in and
I I don't feel very appreciated at home
all the hard work that you do sitting on
your ass
like for ideas and then let it go
through my mouth oh what kind of ideas
give me give me an example of some on
the left someone that rides moving
around up and down yeah yeah we're
having tuna because you look like you're
I did a overhead press and then I
[__] tweaked a little bit how how do
you tweak it um sometimes like on the
last couple of reps I think because I
haven't been really focused on my
recovery and I've been traveling like
crazy I don't I think I'm a little bit
misaligned so with that in mind I think
I should have just like cut every set
one rep short because I probably slept
here on the place left over there in the
hotel slipped over here and then I just
went for that one extra one wasn't even
very hard but it just went oh and I was
like you felt it like a pop yeah
did you finish the rep though that's the
Meathead question always always never
not finish
fine that was good
you remind me of someone who someone so
we have a friend that only talks to us
oh yeah with the side of her eyes uh why
were you on a plan what happened what's
going on catch me up here I live with
you but like I haven't seen you in like
two days can you see this in another
Vlog where I dive really deep into it
but like for this year
it's been like a big goal of ours
actually for like last maybe two years
and probably going on in another one or
two years is to really like set
ourselves up financially you know like
should I can make
on this side you you look like you're
suffering make you like uh like Big Boy
adult big girl moves I like I don't like
the term big what can we just say like
um grown-up woman yeah I'm like big well
I was wrong big I don't want to be
called big dude I want to be a lot of
moves I want to be a dainty little
little
frail woman find a little like a
grown-up moves okay
um you just say okay
I did I got caught yeah and
um so I flew straight into Ohio for like
pretty much a one day business trip you
can fly straight into Ohio yeah okay
cool well how do you fly to Ohio
do I need to say anything okay go it
went straight into Ohio holy [__] who
aggressively opens the door like that
Jesus Christ
Nelly
oh you smell good thank you anyways
that's what I did checked out some
investment opportunities over there and
then uh came back real quick right in
time for JK but you guys will see it
well we were supposed to see each other
you were supposed to fly into Vegas oh
call Fiasco yeah I was supposed to fly
in Thursday night at nine or ten because
there's a time difference and so that's
the time we needed to like check out the
whole property and then I was supposed
to fly out early morning Friday morning
uh Vegas to L.A but in [__] this is
how I know we're so blessed on the west
coast they have blessed on the west yeah
blessing the West because the [__]
East is a beast because over there all
the I'm gonna cut this one I'm gonna cut
this Vlog right now because the [__]
weather's horrendous this is so stupid
the when the weather's horrendous we're
at the airport I was out there at five
right ready for uh keep make the whole
thing rhyme go you were there at five
we're right there at five right on time
and then when it was at seven I was oh
this is heaven but then they [__]
delayed it like a [__]
Jamaican and I was like
and I was like what from seven to nine
to eleven and that I was like that's not
heaven heaven anymore because I haven't
and then I was and then I was like well
[__] it let me get in my steps and then
my partner was like you bet so we walked
up and down the hall and uh like it was
a mall and and then all right I'm over
it got it got it and the [__] they
[__] canceled it I'm like yeah I got
it yeah yeah so I hadn't seen him in two
days I haven't seen him in two days I
just see him now because last night
drove in got in at like nine he still I
think you're eating because you were
filming JK news the whole time
um and I'm just uh he just comes home
and goes I love you we'll talk tomorrow
and I was like all right let's see tired
I haven't I've been sleeping like two
hours a day for the last three days not
a homie yeah and then that's why your
neck is tweaked
yeah because I've been sleeping like
this like this yeah yeah no no yeah I
got it
okay so just finished a few hours of JK
news and I forgot the amount of
endurance you need to do back to back to
back to back to back to back videos we
shoot
um right now they're shooting two
different sessions each session is about
five hours and um so you're doing about
like
be 12 15 videos
um and yeah I'm be I only did half a
session and do the full session length
guys I'm beat so
now I'm back home and look at how cute
this is all the kids are playing
cut it out he didn't he didn't but the
most CUNY part is these two right here
look at them
they've been at it for I don't know how
long I just got home and they look
already so tired look she doesn't give a
[__] like
so that's Shadow and Mia
come on
I go I shouldn't play all day
imagine if humans played like this and
we're just biting each other's skin
it'd be so painful
put bubbles on them oh very cool
no don't put bubbles on them
we're gonna whip them
yeah and they don't want to get wet
no hurt their eyes
okay welcome to the choppiest Vlog ever
this is day two now
of my Vlog maybe even day three honestly
there's my mom we're back in Vegas
comes from her back place
again another scrub her butt how you
guys doing good I'm not gonna I'm
washing her scrub her back she's nice
and cool against the floor like that
I'm not gonna wash her butt why but it's
so dirty I already washed her butt oh
you don't have to wash your butts but
does she like it yeah she's doing really
good good job
okay
we'll leave them it's so humid and hot
in there
so tired just drove for hours didn't
think I'm gonna be tired had a Red Bull
I'm tired now it's Sunday Sundays are my
days where I like get my life together
for the beginning of the week we got the
laundry
the washer ready to go
I really actually wanted to take me home
too because you know what this woman is
so [__] stubborn hence why I'm so
[__] stubborn and she's just like I
don't want to go I want to really help
you organize and stuff so basically she
saw
how my life is in trembles right now
because I'm like you know full-time job
full-time mom
just moved
my shit's all over the place in this
house like I still have [__] that is in
boxes we've been here since August
September October November wait
September October wait
did we spend taika's birthday no
October what did I do for my birthday
dude I don't even remember my birthday
and it was in October what did I do for
my birthday
that sucks
she goes to show you how not present I
am
I don't know oh we moved here in
November beginning of November
right anyway December January two months
no that doesn't even make sense
I'm a [__] [__] show and that is why
my mom is here right now
what the [__] is happening
hey papa are you naked
okay
I have a question for you
well you turned so funny because your
next [__] up
when did we move in here what month
I believe October November
okay what did I do for my birthday
for your birthday I completely forgot
you can't ask me these kind of questions
I know me too I forgot too what did I do
for my birthday uh I set up a big lunch
yes thank you tiny Mexican restaurant I
had the best time of my life
look at Mia she's all clean and fluffy
and very very much confused
new puppy
see you later
cutie pie what about it
no because I was just talking about all
the
I was talking about oh how many like how
we still have boxes and [__] and we've
been living here and I was like gonna do
the math in months yeah and I was like
wait
what did I move in and I couldn't figure
it out yeah I remember October
because a lot of things happened around
that time
like what I'm just kidding I just like
the turn of fall and stuff oh CUNY okay
thank you
took my dad away oh
[__] let's leave let's leave let's leave
let's leave let's sleep
dude it is so cold
in Vegas
we are developing Frost
in our backyard look at that
that is all little ice
isn't that crazy
maybe not for you guys where it snows
because this ain't [__]
but I'm from California and like
we don't get weather our weather's
[__] perfect like all the time bruh
like what is that white stuff out there
like what is that I don't know what that
is and I don't like it okay it feels
really cold and I want it to stop why is
there paper here Mia
what are you eating
no
don't do it walk away no
walk away
walk away what is that what is that did
you eat it
yes you eat beer
did you eat it
Mia Mia
you ate it
you see me as Kenna out there
we went to dinner
and we left her in the kennel because
she's so little we don't know what she's
gonna do
in the house all by herself
and she decided me I'm talking about you
hey Mia
she decided
she was gonna poop in her kennel because
she was so anxious
and not only is she gonna poop in her
kennel right Mia because we don't mind
Mia
she danced in all of her poop
Mia you were dancing in your poop
why would you do that you just got a
bath
so Papa had to give her another bath
and now she's looking her butt
okay so to top that off
we took that with us to California as
you guys saw in the earlier clips and my
mom's dog is an outdoor dog and that guy
stinks they were rolling around in that
thing we didn't get to wash it today
so no this is not where Mia's sleeping
princess has this
cushiony
look at how thick it is my foot just
kind of goes under it
like rug I guess
but I think she's hot and there's like a
slight breeze that comes from our doors
our sliding doors that I think she likes
it cold
I must be the Husky in her huh
all right Mama Mia
do you want to say good night
third face looks crazy how about this
one do I say good night
hi Mia
look at her pause look at her paws are
so cute
you're here you're here
hey hey hey hey
stop liking my camera
did you just lick the [__] on my camera
dude you just smudged my lens
okay
I love you
I love you Mama Mia
good night
here POV you're petting your dog
look at our fur it's so soft
it smells so good
he smells so good
it smells so good okay